actress Jamie Lee Curtis is revealing
new details about her decade-long opioid
addiction in the upcoming issue of
People magazine Curtis says this I had a
10 year run
stealing conniving no one knew the
Halloween star has been sober now for
nearly two decades dr. Tara Narula shows
us how Curtis was able to kick her habit
Tara good morning good rise to a lot of
people about her definitely and Jamie
Lee Curtis says that she was actually
ahead of the curve when it comes to
opioids because she became addicted
before the crisis exploded across the
country she now says getting sober is
her single biggest accomplishment
eclipsing all of her box-office hits in
True Lies Jamie Lee Curtis plays a
housewife who unwittingly gets pulled
into her husband's secret life as a spy
[Music]
while making the movie Curtis had a
secret of her own in opioid addiction
she hid from everyone including her
real-life husband Curtis told People
magazine she became hooked on vicodin in
1989 following minor plastic surgery I
had been working on a movie and the
cameraman made a comment about my eyes
being puffy and I was mortified she said
the rush of opiates was like the feeling
of immersing myself in a warm bath she'd
take pills when she could get him and
however she could get him Curtis told
people's staff writer Johnny dawn she
bought drugs from a stuntman rifled
through friends medicine cabinets and
even stole painkillers from her sister
this was something she'd sort of do at
the end of the day like some people
drink a glass of wine she'd pop a pill
the 59 year old actress has been candid
about her drug problems before like in
this 2002 Entertainment Tonight
interview I don't want to sugarcoat it
I think that these addictions are deadly
now more than a hundred and fifteen
people die every day from opioid
overdoses about 40% of them from a
prescription drug
Ted Costello is a certified addictions
treatment counselor
what's extremely significant to me is
the pride she's taken in her recovery I
think it would be hard for people to
hear that and not get hope
Curtis became sober after her first
recovery meeting in 1999 her family has
a history of drug abuse her half-brother
died from a heroin overdose and her
father was addicted to cocaine she says
she still attends recovery meetings and
tries to help other addicts Rabideau her
for speaking up her father was Tony
Curtis very very famous actor it was
such a powerful statement that she said
this was her biggest accomplishment
bigger than her children her husband her
work thank you to many powerful thank
you very much Tara